in this video i explain to you what
fly's capper is how it is calculated and
how you can interpret the results
let's start right away with the first
question
what do you need the fly scapper for
in general you use the fly scapper
whenever you want to assess the
agreement between more than two raters
in the case of fly's capper the variable
to be measured by the raters is a
nominal variable therefore if you have a
nominal variable you use the fly's kappa
for your information if you had an
ordinal variable and more than two
raters you would use candles w test and
if you had a metric variable you would
use the intra-class correlation
if you had only two raters and a nominal
variable you would use cohen's kappa but
that's enough theory for now let's take
a look at an example
let's say you have developed a measuring
instrument for example a questionnaire
the doctors can use to determine whether
a person is depressed or not
now you give the measuring instrument to
doctors and let them evaluate
50 people with it
the big question now is how well do the
doctor's measurements agree
if the assessments of the doctors agree
very well
one speaks of a high integrator
reliability
and it is precisely this integrator
reliability that the fly's capper
measures
the fly's capper is a measure of
integrator reliability
and the flyscape is therefore a measure
of how reliably more than two raters
measure the same
so far we have considered the case where
more than two people measure the same
thing
however the fly scapper can also be used
when the same rater takes the
measurement at more than two different
times
in that case the fly scapper indicates
how well the measurements of the same
person agree
and in this case the variable understudy
has two characteristics depressive or
non-depressive of course the variable
can also consist of more than two
characteristics
so the fly scapper is a measure of the
agreement between more than two
dependent categorical samples
it is important to note that with fly's
kappa you can only make a statement
about how reliably the raters measure
the same
but you cannot make a statement about
whether what the raters measure is the
right thing or not
so if the raters almost always measure
the same thing
you would have a very high fly scapper
whether this measured value fits with
the reality thus the correct is measured
fly's kappa does not tell you in the
first case one speaks of reliability
and in the second case one speaks of
validity
now of course the question arises how is
fly's kappa calculated
well there are two ways to do this
either you use a statistic software like
data tab or you calculate it by hand of
course knowing how to calculate by hand
will also help you to understand fly's
kappa better we will now go through both
ways first i will show you how to do it
with data tab and then we will look at
the formulas
in order to do this simply go to
datadept.net
and copy your own data into this table
now you click on the tab reliability and
the reliability you can calculate
different reliability statistics
depending on how many variables you
choose and which level of measurement
they have and you will get a suitable
suggestion the fly scap is calculated
for nominal variables if your data was
deducted as metric
please change the level under data view
to nominal
if you now click on rater 1 and rater 2
the cohen's kappa will be calculated
if you further click on rater 3
the fly scapper will be calculated for
you
and here below you can read the
calculated fly scapper if you don't know
how to interpret the result just click
on
interpretations in words
an interrater reliability analysis was
performed between the dependent samples
of rater 1 rater 2 and rater 3. for this
purpose the fly's cap was calculated
which is a measure of the agreement
between more than two dependent
categorical samples the fly's kappa
showed that there was a slight agreement
between samples rater 1 radar 2 and
rater 3
with kappa equals 0.03
and now i will explain to you the
formulas behind the flyscaper and how
you can calculate the fly's kappa by
hand we can calculate the fly's kappa
with this equation in order to do this
we need po which is the observed
agreement of the raters
and we need pe
which is the expected agreement
if the raters judge completely randomly
for example just flip a coin on each
patient to see
if they are depressed or not so how do
we calculate p o and p e let's start
with pe
let's say we have seven patients and
three raters
each patient was rated by each rater in
the first step we simply count how many
times a patient was rated as depressed
and how many times as not depressed for
the first patient sierra rader said that
this person is not depressed and all
raters so three raters said that this
person is
depressed for the second person
one rater said that the person is not
depressed and two raters said that the
person is depressed
now we do that for all the other
patients we can calculate the sum in
each case now in total we have 8 ratings
with not depressed and 13 ratings with
depressed in total there were 21 ratings
this allows us to calculate how likely
it is that a person will be rated as not
depressed or as depressed for this we
divide the number of ratings of
depressive and
not depressive by the total number of
21. so once eight divided by 21 and thus
we get that 38
of the patients are rated as not
depressed by the raters and then another
13 divided by 21 and thus we get that 62
of the patients were rated as depressed
in order to calculate p e now we square
both values and sum them up so 0.38
squared plus 0.62
squared which is equal to 0.53
now we have pe and we still need to
calculate po
po can be calculated with this formula
don't worry it looks more complicated
than it is
let's start with the first part
capital n is the number of patients for
example 7
and small n is the number of raters for
example 3 this gives us 0.024
for the first part in the second part of
the formula we simply square each value
in this table and sum that up so 0
squared plus 3 squared
to finally 1 squared plus 2 squared
that gives 47 and the third part comes
out to 7 times 3 which equals 21.
if we substitute everything we get 0.024
times 47
minus 21
which is equal to 0.6
we now have po and pe when we insert
them into the formula for kappa we
obtain a kappa of 0.19
with this we get
just a slight agreement i hope you
enjoyed the video and see you next time